as a result of my studies I found a
thread that the essence of religion was
compassionate that every single one of
the major world religions Judaism Islam
Christianity Hinduism Buddhism and
Confucianism they all insisted on what's
often known as the golden moon never
treat others as you would not like to be
treated yourself the wish was that we
get a panel of activists and together we
would craft a charter a brief statement
reminding the world that this is what
religion is about they had a big idea to
change the world
but they couldn't do it alone so my wish
from I wish I wish my wish and now
here's my wish our nation seemed to be
crumbling by the day and this should
make us uncomfortable
we've all got new problems in our cities
problems of inequity and cruelty and
violence so what can we do what can we
do to change things every city has to be
compassionate our people often ask me
what should a compassionate city be like
and I said well a compassionate city
should be an uncomfortable City one is
Louisville Kentucky where the Mayor Greg
Fischer actually campaigned on that idea
of compassion when he announced
compassion is a city value it got a lot
of attention a city is a platform for
human potential to come alive compassion
makes individuals stronger and makes our
city stronger
people does cargill themselves a
compassionate City unless they've got a
practical course of action
[Music]
so the question then is how do you bring
compassion a lot how do you change the
culture of your city what if you could
start at the beginning of a young
child's life
[Music]
my name is Megan Clem Mattingly I am the
compassionate schools project teacher
compassion is a very teachable thing
okay I see a lot of friends who are
looking ready every CSP class begins
with calming and focusing and then we
have some sort of core practice that
we're doing whether we're talking about
self-awareness or empathy building
skills and then we are starting at the
ground level and we're building that
foundation for our students at age five
and up to be more compassionate citizens
goodbye Jeremy look at miss Maddie we do
jeremiah we're gonna try harder to get
ourselves regulation back sir jeremiah
come here i need you to tell me more
about that
jeremiah come here anger frustration
which feeling was bringing anger i can
tell a trance so before we talk about it
can you calm yourself down
now it's hard to and so can you try to
make your hands look like mine
what do you try to let go with that look
at your face I see a smile there you're
trying real hard to hang on to that
anger I see everyday these changes
happening in these students and I have
all the hope in the world that this
project will will change our education
we define compassion as respect for each
and every one of our citizens so that
their human potential is flourishing
thriving grant me the serenity to accept
the things that I cannot change the
courage to change the things that I can
and the wisdom to know the difference
just for today keep coming back
it works Hotel Louisville is a great
example of how to think about the whole
system of getting a person back on track
so it's a shelter for women and their
families but it's also an operating
Hotel Hotel Oh was not just a women's
rehab facility as a workforce program we
run the hotel we do all the jobs here
every job that one of us have just has
their own individual skills it gives us
a sense of responsibility because we can
put this on our resumes
I think the compassion really comes from
the girls that are in the rehab because
we depend on each other a lot we need
each other
[Music]
if I was not here at Hotel oh well I
would be sitting in jail doing my time I
was giving that chance and I just I want
to live I want to live life
[Music]
and it lifts us all up to say this is
the kind of city we are and this is the
kind of city we aspire to be and that
any way we can help other cities and to
make take us to even greater heights is
what we want to do it's this ripple
effect
we're not perfect as a city before we're
working to be better every day
here you have a city which is doing
great things with compassion
city's and mayor's are going to play an
important role as leaders of the future
[Music]
I like to see a thousand compassionate
cities in the next decade that remind
the rest of the world what our duty is
[Music]
always treat all others as you'd like to
be treated yourself
[Music]
[Music]